[Música]
Bienvenidos a enlace Norteamérica desde
Ciudad de México voy abordaremos la
evolución de los derechos de las mujeres
en un país en el que cada día en
promedio son asesinadas diez mexicanas
el derecho a una vida libre de violencia
es sin duda el tema pendiente sin
embargo hay avances en otros rubros como
el derecho a la salud los derechos
sexuales y reproductivos y derechos
políticos El problema es que si bien se
han ido rompiendo barreras persisten
obstáculos por vencer
apenas en 1953 se reconoció en México el
derecho de las mujeres a votar en unas
elecciones y fue en 1955 cuando
sufragaron por primera vez desde
entonces han ido ganando terreno
en 2014 se garantizó en la Constitución
la paridad entre mujeres y hombres en
las candidaturas al poder legislativo
Pero sigue habiendo resistencias y aún
hay pendientes para lograr la igualdad
de condiciones la consejera electoral
Norma de la cruz nos Comenta al respecto
que tenerlo en la ley paridad no es
suficiente porque por ejemplo a nivel de
gobernaturas a pesar de que las mujeres
han votado desde el 2000 de 1955 hasta
el 2021 en junio antes de la elección
solo se habían elegido siete mujeres
como gobernadoras Entonces de quién nos
habla de no es lo mismo tener acceso el
derecho al voto que el derecho a ser
votada verdad además si bien
numéricamente hay paridad la realidad
muestra que no se ha alcanzado la
igualdad sustantiva
Es bien interesante porque tenemos la
legislatura de la paridad y la inclusión
son 250 mujeres y 250 hombres Cuántas
mujeres coordinan una fracción
parlamentaria ninguna Por otra parte no
es lo mismo ser mujer política en las
grandes ciudades que ejercer un cargo en
localidades apartadas Aunque tengamos
paridad en los congresos Aunque hasta
tenemos ya
los gabinetes en varios estados o en
paritarios no hay más mujeres resulta
que a nivel municipal no solo hay menos
presidentes municipales y a nivel de
regidurías estamos estamos casi en
paridad pero ahí es donde las mujeres en
esos cargos sufren más violencia
en 2007 en la capital del país se
despenalizó el aborto luego de más de
una década de lucha feminista en
septiembre de 2021 la suprema corte de
justicia declaró inconstitucional
criminalizar la interrupción del
embarazo Cuáles son los alcances de esta
sentencia histórica y cuáles siguen
siendo los escollos para que las mujeres
puedan decidir libremente sobre su
cuerpo e interrumpir de manera segura su
embarazo la ministra de la corte
Margarita Ríos fat lo explica así
es una decisión generalizada a todo el
país a todo el orden jurídico mexicano Y
qué va a representar pues es un
reconocimiento
a que el estado nos estaba haciendo
cargo de una necesidad algo que sucedía
en la clandestinidad lo que está
sucediendo lo que debe representar ahora
esta decisión es que lo que sucedía en
la clandestinidad tenga condiciones de
salud de seguridad para el beneficio de
todas las mujeres sin embargo hay
estados del país que no han armonizado
aún sus códigos penales y siguen
considerando el delito de aborto es una
por eso hablo de una falta de empatía
aéreo solidaridad porque quien ya se ha
determinado a ser madre lo va a hacer
estemos en el código pero si el código
dice que es delito el código local va a
regresar a las prácticas clandestinas y
creo que creo que eso es justamente el
obstáculo la discusión sobre el aborto
ha dejado ver estigmas y prejuicios yo
no creo que se vayan a disparar este los
abortos no lo creo y es más el hecho de
que esa perspectiva de alguna manera
permee y haya sido la dominante mucho
tiempo ha sido una cosa que ha lastimado
a las mujeres a lo largo de los años en
cuanto a los derechos a la salud en
febrero de 2023 en el congreso de la
Ciudad de México se aprobó un exhorto a
legislativo Federal para que se
establezcan permisos con goce de sueldo
a quienes se han diagnosticadas con
dismenorrea discapacitante esto y la
eliminación de impuestos a los productos
de gestión menstrual han sido la batalla
de activistas como Anahí Rodríguez
gracias a todo el trabajo de nuestro
activismo en México ahora las mujeres y
otras personas menestrantes No pagamos
un dieciséis por ciento por toallas
tampones y copas esta tasa cero es
temporal para que sea algo permanente la
suprema corte de justicia tendría que
declarar discriminatorio el impuesto a
productos menstruales las activistas
están en ello pero al mismo tiempo
luchan porque las menores tengan acceso
gratuito a los productos también hemos
impulsado la gratuidad de productos de
gestión menstrual que son toallas
tampones y copas principalmente en la
educación básica obligatoria pública
Michoacán fue el primer estado en marzo
del 2021 que aprobó esta reforma a la
ley de Educación y de ahí continuaron
diez estados más todos estos avances si
bien son importantes no son ni serán
suficientes mientras sigue en México la
tendencia de la violencia hacia las
mujeres desde 2019 se mantienen cifras
de más de 960 feminicidios al año es
decir aquellos asesinatos en razón de
género Pero además otros delitos contra
las mujeres como homicidio culposo
lesiones dolosas extorsión y corrupción
de menores registraron en 2022 un máximo
histórico en cuanto al número de
víctimas en este país por ello El grito
y la exigencia siguen siendo ni una
menos
Gracias por acompañarnos en una emisión
más de enlace Norteamérica desde Ciudad
de México soy Mario carbonel y mi
compañera en cámara Lizeth Romero Hasta
pronto